stockholm la capitale de la suède
ici comme partout ailleurs dans ce pays
scandinave cette image nocturne est plus
que familières les suédois sont parmi
les plus grands consommateurs de
journaux au monde et ils sont choyés
[Musique]
ce pays de 10 millions d'habitants
compte plus de 150 quotidiens 15 par un
million d'habitants
c'est cinq fois plus que la moyenne
européenne six fois plus fort canada
[Musique]
martin johnson travail pour dagen
signataires le principal quotidien
suédois qui existe depuis cent cinquante
cinq ans et tire à près de 300000
exemplaires par jour sa version internet
compte cent soixante dix mille abonnés
c'est un journal qui va très bien et qui
est même en expansion 200 journalistes y
travaillent dont 10 correspondants
étrangers dont l'accent sur des
reportages de qualité sur l' enquête
nous avons augmenté le nombre de
correspondants étrangers à nous
consacrons moins d'espacés ouverts
général disponible gratuitement partout
nous misons sur une couverture unique
qui nous est propre
ce joyau de la presse suédoise ne reçoit
aucune aide directe du gouvernement
c'est pourtant le cas de la moitié des
journaux du pays
sans l'argent du gouvernement
nous serions obligés de revoir notre
édition papier d'augmenter de beaucoup
le prix de l'abonnement
le nombre d'employés et ce local très
central tout cela devrait être revu
[Musique]
nous sommes assez d'airtel 30 km au sud
ouest de stockholm
avec ses 75 mille habitants cette ville
industrielle se distingue par une
importante population immigrante et une
forte croissance démographique
l'an dernier le journal local lan ce
single a publié une série d'articles sur
les mauvais traitements subis dans cet
hôpital par les patients des
départements de gériatrie et de
psychiatrie l'impact a été immédiat
nous sommes près de la capitale et les
journaux nationaux couvrent parfois
certains sujets d'ici mais il ne traite
pas des entreprises et des politiciens
locaux ni des habitants qui subissent
des mauvais traitements par exemple il
n'était rappelle pas les autorités là
dessus ça mais sans la subvention de
l'état l'équivalent de plus de deux
millions de dollars canadiens par année
ce seul journal local qui existe depuis
plus de 150 ans aurait du mal à tirer
son épingle du jeu
je pense que nous jouons un rôle
important dans la vie démocratique ici
ça a été l'aide gouvernementale à la
presse suédoise c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent cette année en 2019 l'état
suédois a distribué l'équivalent de 92
millions de dollars canadiens aux
journaux d'ici c'est une augmentation de
près de 50% par rapport à l'an dernier
un exemple svenska dagbladet le deuxième
quotidienne de la capitale
deux cent mille abonnés a reçu
l'équivalent de près de 6 millions de
dollars canadiens j'ai là de lèse
personne de fort benning à ce quotidien
conservateur bénéficient de l'aide
gouvernementale depuis longtemps car
l'état suédois favorise la pluralité des
opinions politiques
traditionnellement c'est le second
journal en importance sur un marché
donné qui se qualifiait pour l'aide
gouvernementale
les éditeurs de dagany et air plutôt du
centre gauche est numéro 1 à stockholm
n'était pas toujours très heureux il y a
dix on était très critique après tout
pourquoi recevra-t-il toutes ces grosses
sommes d'argent essentiellement pour
faire la même chose que nous
et puis tout a changé avec l'arrivée des
géants du numérique
penses tu es tu as ta nièce au cours des
dix dernières années les journaux
suédois ont perdus annuellement
l'équivalent de 80 millions de dollars
canadiens en revenus publicitaires au
profit de google et facebook google et
facebook qui tout comme au canada ne
paie pas un sou d'impôt le débat sur
l'injustice du système qui subventionne
certains journaux et pas d'autres
c'était avant google et facebook
aujourd'hui tous les journaux sont dans
le même bateau c'est bon pour tout le
monde qu'il y ait beaucoup de journaux
différents
ça nous pousse à faire de l'information
de qualité
[Musique]
pour cet ancien rédacteur en chef de
svenska dagbladet membre du parti
conservateur
il faut aller plus loin il vient de
prendre position publiquement pour qu'on
augmente sérieusement le financement des
journaux au même niveau que la
télévision et la radio publiques qui
sont entièrement à la charge de l'état
quand on conduit une voiture c'est bien
d'avoir une route n'est ce pas ce ces
infrastructures sont nécessaires de la
même manière des journaux la télévision
et la radio publiques sont des
infrastructures nécessaires à la
démocratie démocratique politics
aujourd'hui en suède l'aide directe de
l'état à la presse écrite électronique
fait l'unanimité elle a permis aux
journaux suédois non seulement de
survivre mais de croître et de se
moderniser et si elle n'a pas empêché
une certaine concentration de la presse
entre les mains de quelques grands
groupes
elle a permis de sauvegarder la
pluralité de points de vue est
essentielle
démocratie